[Music]
I'm back on top
[Music]
okay you've had your shop it's my time
now Luca if anyone's taking the MVP item
from yogurtz it's the winner of last
year's onesie and how'd that work out
for you
the wonders of This Strange Land never
cease to amaze
you guys coming
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man Yoki says everything for 1.6
kilometer high city this is why an elite
fighter like you or me must stop him
from getting a third idle oh so you're
Giannis is level now
okay
[Music]
this is the closest I've been that's a
real trophy
[Music]
oh
another Giannis world
point guard show me the way huh Chris
Deandre
I will I am used to being alone hello
here we go
figure Market are we really doubling in
open combat almost ready
I have many weapons in my Arsenal
ah
in the back who does that
it's what I am without looking I don't
know if I can beat him without help
hey man this place is very nice
oh
you had one job Joker the association's
displeased
you know I live online
Channel your rage at stopping fees
targets
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]